(dramatic music)
(beeping)
(gasping)
(Bonko sniffs)
- Who you man?
What you doing?
- Hey buddy.
You just woke up from your coma.
Name's Bonko, the god
damn hospital clown
with the funk up, bro.
- Are those my pills?
- Yeah man, sorry.
My career's been deader
than David Bowie and Prince,
so hence the medicine.
- Prince and Bowie died?
- Oh yeah, that's right.
You don't know dick about fuck.
A lot of dumb mother fucks died
while you were in that coma.
Like a bitch Carrie Fisher.
- No.
- And the mother
fucker Harrison Ford's.
- I don't care about.
- Character Han Solo.
- Han Solo died?
Oh no.
- You a big Han Solo fan?
- No man, I just hate spoilers.
- We also lost poor Zsa Zsa.
- Zsa Zsa?
- Zsa Zsa Gabor, the actress.
- No.
- She was kind of an actress.
She slapped that cop.
- Oh, Zsa Zsa, that's fine.
I thought you were doing
an all Star Wars thing.
- No, I'd never do
that to someone.
I'm not a fucking nerd.
- Hey man, give me my pill.
- Get off, bro, you
get off my shit.
I'm just fucked up ever
since Ringling Brothers
made the announcement that
they were pulling the plug
on all operation.
- The Ringling Brothers?
- Yeah, why do you think
I'm a hospital clown?
- They killed the
greatest show on earth.
(beeping)
- Hello?
- Clear.
- Hey, can I get a
light off one of those?